alors après l'épisode fontainebleau de
retour à constantine tu retrouves suzy
et avait patiemment attendu oui
gentiment oui elle m'a vue bien attendu
et moi même j'ai été surpris ouais parce
que j'ai eu beaucoup d'autres
expériences s'appuie à chaque fois que
que je revoyais j'étais tout le temps à
mon alors ton père lui tient toujours à
ce que tu es une profession sérieuse et
il exige enfin que tu sois instituteurs
ou petits élèves aux petits arabes qui
étaient des élèves je leur apprenais de
nos ancêtres les gaulois non à huy ah
oui oui oui il ya quand même non après
oui par la suite
bon d'accord
à
j'ai vu j'ai mis ça n'est pas vrai j'ai
refusé j'ai vu que honda effet un
raccord maquillage rôle d'un raccord
maquillage il faisait des choses comme
ça des petits élèves au il s'amusait
bien avec moi s'amusait bien et puis moi
j'ai une anecdote avec mes petits élèves
c'est que quand c'est pas mal ça n'a pas
que les pieds noirs
un jeu défouloir et alors qu on
enseigner ce qu'on appelle la méthode
globale
la méthode globale en prenez par exemple
les verts ont cassé le vert et je disais
aux élèves café le m ouais alors qu'ils
apprennent une phrase entière le net a
cassé un verre
ouais et ce jour là c'était le maître
regarde une image alors inventé moi toi
une scène pour regarder une image ans
j'ai posé des mises des images de
parthenay et je courrai à droite et moi
je veux garder l'image comme ça comme ça
j'allais rien le vide le plus complet
que fait le m rien que peut le mettre à
la fin il y en a un qui les veulent je
dis que fait le maître l1 qui lève le
doigt j je suis sauvé même s'il dit une
bêtise c'est pas grave ça va enclencher
quelque chose il lève le doigt j alors
que fut le maître il me dit le maître
fait des kilomètres
on va les séparer
on a tenté
six enfants
et
difficile
ceux-là
à cette époque là est ce que tu sentais
que tu vivais les derniers temps d'une
période paisible oui oui
déjà c'était bien endommagée quoi ça
veut dire que tout était bouleversée on
était en pleine guerre quoi un com com
comme ça se passe en ce moment un même
si je dois dire c'est comme en
yougoslavie en ce moment où même
dernièrement au liban c'était comme ça
bon par exemple on avait des copains on
se donnait rendez-vous et on savait en
faisait les comptes le soir on savait
pas si on allait rentrer chez nous le
soir à la maison c'était aussi
dramatique que cela fit poser des
questions sur le désir d'indépendance
des algériens tu réagis sait comment
nous on réagisse et chacun
son intérêt c'est à dire notre on était
français on était pour que l'algérie
reste française surtout qu'on nous
faisait des promesses à l'époque on nous
disait vous inquiétez pas l'algérie sera
française je vous ai compris tout c'est
bon on va pas revenir là dessus on va
pas refaire l'histoire
je trouve que bon c'est l'époque où
tombe au père a été assassiné il a été
assassiné comment mon beau-père et
méritait pas d'être tué parce que
c'était un grand artiste et puis surtout
un homme bon quoi mériter pas mérité pas
puis restitués par un lingot lui tout ça
pour parce que il était le représentant
de la communauté juive de constantine et
que les algériens en le tuant et il
avait signifié à tous les juifs de
constantine et puis même aux pieds noirs
de constantine qu'il fallait partir
quand ils nous ont tués tonton raymond
qui était mon beau père il avait tué
notre cv notre les fondations mêmes de
notre communauté
les algériens étaient jaloux un petit
peu de la nationalité française des
juifs d'algérie qui datait de la fin du
siècle dernier avec le décret crémieux
c'est ça c'est quand le crémieux afld a
décrété que les juifs devaient être ans
et je comprends pas pourquoi il n'a pas
fait le même décret pour tous les
habitants de l'algérie est captée on a
dû subir les conséquences toute façon
tous les gens nous jalousent à nous la
communauté juive ce que ce soit les
les gens d'extrême droite les fascistes
pouvait pas nous voir parce que il y en
a qui réussissent chez nous alors on dit
en généralistes facilement évidemment
c'est les juifs qui réussissent mieux
que les autres et puis ceux qui ne
pouvaient pas nous voir il avait comme
prétexte disait oui évidemment ils sont
chouchoutés par le gouvernement français
ils sont plus français que l'école est
musulman alors ils nous ont divisés pour
que les autres règne à la mort de son
beau père tu jures d'épouser suzy la
mort de mon beau père a été mon premier
mariage avec suzy parce que de toute
façon même si je n'étais pas marié avec
suzy nos deux familles et elle y est
et comme j'étais un peu l'aîné des
enfants des deux familles jeu j'étais
considéré un peu comme le responsable
et alors là vous décidez tous de partir
vous avez pris la décision quand tout de
suite quand mon beau père a été tué le
temps de
l'enterrer j'étais obligé de partir s'il
ya vraiment des c'était la valise ou le
cercueil quoi c'était ça c'est de la
valise et le cercueil malheureusement
malheureusement on aurait pu éviter
l'indépendance de l'algérie s'est pas
seulement l'indépendance qu'on aurait pu
éviter mais au moins au moins les morts
moi ce que je n'arrive pas à comprendre
jusqu'à présent je comprendrais jamais
jusqu'à maman c'est que il ya toujours
des tapis vert
une fois que les gens s'entretuent je
comprends pas qu'ils aient pas déjà des
tapis vert avant que les gens entre eux
vivent les parties comment on est parti
sur le bateau si drogba
philippe billy qui dit que dans le
bateau les hommes se cacher dans les
coursives pour pleurer c'est terrible
cette traversée draoui moi c'est mon
image que j'ai c'est ma grand mère ma
grand mère qui était vraiment déguisé
parce que elle et elle avait l'habitude
d'être habillé en indigènes coin qu'on
était habillé là bas et puis l'année
tablier avec une robe
c'était elle ressemble à une vraie
française oui et je la vois encore avec
cette ce tailleur de couleur marron
foncé c'était plus ma grand mère
c'est une autre femme les a emportés
quoi on n'a rien emporter je me rappelle
que ma mère et ma belle-mère ont dû
retourner ou pour prendre des choses
précieuses ou de là bas mais quand on
est parti on n'avait pas le temps de rap
et de la terre nous avons emporté non
même pas non non